hello core name is Sara Mednick I'm one
of the Schwab social entrepreneurs on
founder and chair of IDA a
singapore-based social enterprise which
aspires to be the world's micro business
school we provide financial and
management education to the world's
total floor I serve this moderator today
for one of the luncheon sessions at web
cut the title was disrupted aspirations
closing the income gap obviously in this
session we were engaged with the core
questions of poverty what is poverty how
do we serve an already is it even very
reasonable that we could conceive of
solving problems in our lifetimes the
central messages that came out of the
session dworld really that poverty is a
is a complex issue there is no silver
bullet and it is neither of us to
imagine that there is a single or
simplistic and set of solutions even one
participant suggested that we've come a
bit more humble and I think that comment
touched us all in the blow and we left
the session with an understanding that
this is one of the world's greatest
issues that each one of us must be
involved in implicated with the solution
this is not a solution that's left to
government to civil society to
businesses or even to the poor
themselves all of us must be used in
Italy involved in finding the solution
in ourselves perhaps in the options that
we work through on a day-to-day basis I
have also been asked to consider a
question what are you doing to compat
issues such as sex trafficking money
laundering slavery and exploitation of
women and children do you think you've
done enough
certainly no no one could ever do enough
as long as the slavery and exploitation
of women and children exists we will not
have done enough we must eradicate these
things but I would suggest that my
organization is working very hard to
take away one of the central
vulnerabilities of women and a Magister
the provision of financial education you
must be able to manage their money make
their money be be entrepreneurs and
generators of England some of the cells
in the family since when they have a
certain level of economic stability that
they will be safe from those who would
exploit them ok thank you